if you ever found yourself being
attacked by a velociraptor you'd
probably wet your pants and run away
screaming with that in mind it's
impossible not to lose total faith in
Jurassic part The Lost World when Kelly
Malcolm the spunky daughter of Dr Ian
Malcolm stands her ground against one of
the lethal dinosaurs by putting her
gymnastic training to the test watching
a kid hold her own against one of the
franchise's nastiest villains is
undeniably cool but the way she does it
hauling off and kicking the creature
through a window is entirely
unbelievable sure this is a movie about
dinosaurs being brought back to life but
dino fighting gymnastics skills are just
A Bridge Too Far